2002 was the fifth hottest year on
global records stretching back more than
a century the government report says
when you look at nine of the past 10
years
they're the warmest years in the modern
records since 1880. now that's pretty
alarming
climate scientists say the warming is
caused by Industrial Age heat trapping
gas emissions which have been rising
steeply since the 1960s they say rapid
reductions in emissions are needed
across the globe to slow or reverse the
greenhouse effect
extreme weather events in 2022 include
devastating floods in Pakistan caused by
heavy rainfall and severe drought in
Europe that dried up rivers and sparked
wildfires in the U.S there was
catastrophic flooding in the Appalachian
region and hurricane Ian one of the
strongest storms on record lashed the
State of Florida its warning all of us
forest fires are intensifying hurricanes
are getting stronger droughts are
wrecking Havoc sea levels are rising the
economic cost in the U.S of extreme
weather events was more than
165 billion dollars we need to be
prepared for the impacts of climate
change that are happening here and now
like the more frequent and destructive
extreme events at least 474 people died
in those extreme events in the U.S last
year if 2022 was a bad year for weather
2023 isn't shaping up to be much better
already here in California a series of
severe storms has battered the coastline
and the interior of the state causing a
number of deaths and up to a billion
dollars in Damages Rob Reynolds Al
Jazeera Santa Cruz California